[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRIS KLEBAN: The Cloud
OnAir, live webinars
from Google Cloud.
We host these webinars
every Tuesday.
And my name is Chris Kleban.
And today, I'll be
talking about cloud GPUs.
You can ask questions
any time on the platform,
and we have Googlers
standing by to answer them.
So let's get started.
So if you're out
in the audience,
live or watching
the recording, let
me just spend a
couple of minutes
talking about what a GPU
is, in case you don't know.
So as this picture shows,
GPUs started with gaming.
My mom would play
Frogger back when
I was a little baby, trying to
get that frog across the road
or over the river.
I played Nintendo,
Super Mario Bros.,
going down the pipes
and the secret warps.
And my son now plays Minecraft
on his Xbox with his friends.
And over the time
of these generations
of gaming in my
family, the graphics
have gotten better and better.
And those graphics
have gotten better,
thanks to a little hardware
chip called the GPU.
These GPUs are everywhere.
They're in your cell
phones, and your laptops,
and your game consoles, and
your PCs under your desk.
And for data centers
and Cloud, what we do
is we take that small GPU
and make a really big one.
And that big GPU--
you'll see a picture of
three of them stacked one
on top of the other--
we put them in servers.
And like GPUs do for gaming,
GPUs in the data center
do for computing.
Gaming needs lots
of things drawn
on the screen in real-time,
scientific research needs
lots of math done as fast
and as quickly as possible.
So how does GPU
acceleration compute work?
Well, you take some
application code--
it can be written in
Python, C++, TensorFlow,
anything you want--
and all that code
mostly runs on the CPU.
The CPU does things
sequentially,
one after the time.
There's an if-then logic.
But what if your
application code has
a bunch of math it wants to do?
Instead of doing
it one at a time
and taking a long
time, what if you do
that math all at the same time?
So the code in the
green, the math part,
let's ship that to the
GPU that could do it fast.
Let's multiply 10 numbers
together, 100, a million,
a billion, get it done
quickly, put the results back
to the CPU.
And in essence, that's
GPU accelerated compute.
Together, it's speeding
up your applications.
So what kind of workloads
are we talking about here?
The first one's machine
learning, right?
GPUs are all about machine
learning and AI these days.
And there's two types
of workloads-- training
and inference.
Training is about building the
artificial intelligence logic,
birthing it, if you will, right?
It's not a person saying,
well, if the car sees a human,
you better hit the brakes,
you better turn left,
you better turn right.
It's not about that at all.
It's about putting a bunch
of data, synthetic or actual,
through some logic, having
the computer system learn what
the right behaviors are or learn
how to find a cat in a photo
and build that
AI's intelligence.
And then machine
learning inference
is, once you have
that intelligence,
it's doing something with it.
Google Photos is this
great app, for example.
And it does search, right?
I have 100,000
pictures of my kids,
but it's really hard to find the
picture that I'm looking for.
Well, on Google
Photos, I can just
click the picture of my
son, Aiden, type in the word
"beach", and it predicts
and finds really quickly,
with accelerated hardware, all
the pictures I'm looking for.
And a user doesn't want to
wait five minutes, 10 minutes
to find that, they
want it automatically.
And that's what inference is--
using the AI to do something.
GPU acceleration is also great
for HPC, or high performance
computing workloads.
Here, we're talking about
weather simulations,
engineering, seismic analysis,
a bunch of things that
typically run on grid systems.
And then there's the
classic visualization case.
It could be gaming, or it could
be a working professional that
might have a workstation
under their desk
with expensive GPU hardware.
And maybe the cloud GPU is
a better approach there.
So those are a few
workloads done by GPUs.
So let's talk about one
of the first 99 problems,
but a cloud GPU ain't one.
The first problem is about
access to compute power.
So we asked a bunch of AI
researchers and experts,
what are the things that
contribute to all the AI
advances?
80% of them said, one
of the main reasons
was just access to raw,
high power compute.
That's amazing, right?
It's not necessarily that we're
learning to do new things,
it's just access to
more power that's
really driving things forward.
On the other hand,
we asked people
coming to TensorFlow
organization, which
is an open source machine
learning algorithm creation
framework, we asked them,
what are the problems you
have with building AI?
And a large majority
of them said, well,
we just don't have access
to the compute we need.
So here we have this problem.
Access to compute
drives innovation.
People trying to innovate
don't have access to compute.
So there has to be a better way.
So according to an
article on time.com,
if you wanted to buy
a supercomputer, one
of the largest
computers in the world,
it might cost you $100
million or $250 million.
That's a lot of money.
On the top 500 list, which
lists the biggest supercomputers
in the world, back in 2008,
the number one supercomputer
had 1,456 teraflops.
That's a lot of power.
But imagine if you're
a researcher working
on a really important
business problem, like I want
to get some recommendations
for online shopping,
or I want to innovate
with self-driving cars.
And let's say you went to your
CTO, your director, and said,
can I please buy a
supercomputer for $100 million?
You would be laughed at not
because the business problem
isn't real, just that spending
that capital upfront is crazy.
So let's talk about
the alternatives.
Let's say we take 1,000
K80 GPUs on Google Cloud
and created a
cluster for an hour.
Using regular, on-demand pricing
it would cost you about $500
for those 1,000 GPUs
to run an experiment,
to see if what you're
working on will do the thing
you need for your business.
And if you use something called
preemptible GPUs, which we'll
talk about later, you
could even drive down
that cost even more to
$250 an hour or less.
So now let's say you have
the same conversation
with your IT director,
who manages the budget,
and say, I want to solve this
really important business
problem.
I want to do some
quick innovation
tests to see if this
is going to work.
Do you all mind if I spin up
this cluster, a super compute
worth of power, spend $250?
Well, you'll be
laughed at again,
but not because they're
going to say no.
They're going to say, of
course, just go do that.
So that's the power
of Google Cloud--
bringing you scale of compute.
And let's go ahead
and show you a demo
of what it looks like to spin up
a cluster of compute instances.
So what I'm showing
you now, this
is the Google Cloud console.
Google Cloud, if you go
over to the top left,
you'll see there's a
lot of services here.
There's VM instances,
instance groups.
And what we are, we're
in the Compute Engine.
This is all about
infrastructure as a service.
And what I'll show you is
how to do an instance group.
And what an instance group
is, is a logical entity
of infrastructure.
It could be one server, it could
be 1,000, it could be 10,000.
And you use those
instance groups
to run a series of workloads.
You can scale it
up, scale it down.
You could have Google
auto-scale it, based on load.
So to create an instance
group, click on a button,
give it a name.
We're going to call
this Cloud OnAir 5.
We are going to pick a single
zone, because we only care
about doing this experiment.
We're going to pick a region.
Plenty of regions
to choose from.
We'll pick Asia East One,
Asia East One A, as a zone.
And there's two kind
of instance groups--
a managed instance group, and
an unmanaged instance group.
Managed instance group, we
can do a lot of things for.
We could do rolling updates,
roll your code forward,
roll it back.
We could do auto-scaling,
load balancing.
Now, for this demo,
we'll pick this.
For instance templates,
this is where
you go ahead and pick a template
to create a virtual machine.
And here, you're going to pick
the size of the VM, the shape,
and all of that.
So we're going to go ahead and
customize an instance template.
We'll pick the number of CPUs
we want, anywhere from 1 to 96.
We'll pick the amount
of memory we want,
and we'll go look at GPUs.
In this case, we
want one GPU per VM.
And since this is a demo,
let's just do one core.
And let's do four
gigabytes of RAM.
Let's do one GPU.
Let's give it an
operating system.
Here, there's plenty
to choose from--
application images, OS
images, custom images.
In this case, we'll
just pick Ubuntu
with a standard
disc or an SSD disc.
Maybe this is machine learning,
so we want to go fast.
And we'll pick a 10
gigabyte SSD back disc.
We'll save this image,
or this template,
called instance template one.
So now that we have this
template, all we need to do
is create 1,000 copies of this.
So we'll go down
to Auto-scaling.
We'll turn this
off, because we want
to create a static cluster.
And for this demo, we'll just
put number of instances as 1
for now.
And we'll hit create.
So now Google Cloud's creating
this logical group in Asia
with one VM.
It's going to give each of those
VMs an IP address, an SSH key.
It's going to secure it in
your own private network.
It's going to have NVIDIA
drivers installed with CUDA.
Depending on your
application, you
can go ahead and pre-install
your application,
like TensorFlow, or
whatever you need.
If you click on the
logic group, you'll
see that there's one
instance installed.
It has an IP
address, an external.
You can go over to the
Details tab and look
at what kind of instance
template was used,
whether or not
auto-scaling was on.
You can go over to
Monitoring to see
things like how
much CPU utilization
your cluster is using, or the
size of the cluster over time,
and so on and so forth.
If you go to the
instance, you can
go in and SSH to the instance
that was just created.
And since we want
a supercomputer,
we want 1,000 VMs all at once.
We want to run that experiment
really quickly-- super compute
power.
We don't want one,
we want 10,000.
So I'm going to change the
number of instances to 1,000,
and I'm going to hit Save.
And now what Google
Cloud's going to do,
it's going to spin
up and it's going
to create 1,000
instances, all of them
with the infrastructure I need,
the applications installed.
And I'm going to be able to
use that for my workloads.
It's going to take
a few minutes.
And for the sake of
time, we'll keep going.
But just like that,
you get a supercomputer
in a matter of minutes
for an affordable price.
So let's switch back.
So we talked a little
bit about scale.
We talked about GPUs,
why they're important.
Now, let's double click
on AI a little bit.
Businesses no longer
have the option just
to skip artificial intelligence
and machine learning.
It's innovate or die.
How can I differentiate
myself from the competitors?
How can I reduce costs?
How can I do something new?
How can I disrupt an industry?
So these are things
that are happening now,
and every organization
around the world
is starting to think about
it and implementing it.
And who better to partner with
on artificial intelligence
than Google?
Google has been an AI
company from birth.
Google Search is well-known
for giving the best results.
Waymo, self-driving cars, we're
working on that technology
to bring that to the masses.
I've already talked about Google
Photos and how that uses AI.
And I particularly
also love YouTube.
My kids who borrow my phone,
use YouTube all the time.
And now when I
pick up YouTube, I
get recommendations
for things like,
do you want to see Daniel Tiger?
You know, I don't,
but I know my kids do.
And we've built in these
artificial intelligence
features into our products.
The blue graph that you're
seeing on the page, this
is showing you the
number of projects
internal at Google that
have the Google Brain AI
model built into them.
As you can see, exponential
growth with a number of things
internally that we're doing
with artificial intelligence.
But why partner with Google
on ML with GPUs and otherwise?
We already talked about scale.
We talked about how
easy it is to go
get yourself a supercomputer.
We talked about speed and why
GPUs are really important.
It's about doing
your compute faster.
If you do what you
need to do on CPUs,
it's going to take you a really
long time for these workloads,
and you don't want to wait.
So why not offload to GPUs?
We showed you the K80, which
is a few generations old GPU
by now.
But we also have the
P100 and the V100--
newer generations
that are faster,
if you want ultra
high performance.
We've also come out
with a Cloud TPU.
This is an ASIC, or a
little chip just like a GPU,
but it's specific
for machine learning.
So if you're running
in TensorFlow,
you could write ML code
on CPU, GPU, or TPU.
And if you pick
Google Cloud, you
can rest assured
that we'll always
have the fastest infrastructure
for you, regardless
of whatever you want to choose.
So if you don't want to
deal with infrastructure,
we also have a suite
of services in AI.
Let's talk about the
quality of our AI models.
If you're just a programmer
running Python or building
web apps, and you don't want to
worry about doing your own HPC
or ML clusters, we have AI
services backed by APIs--
Google Image recognition,
translation, video analysis,
all of these that are
just an API call away,
do a prediction for you
with super high quality.
Or maybe you do want
a custom ML model.
We have a brand new
service called AutoML,
and I really love this.
This is machine learning
creating machine learning.
One of our customers--
customer is Disney--
they came and they said, we
have these Disney products,
and we want our customers
to be able to search
online for the right product.
And we want to use
Google expertise
to build this image
recognition system.
Can you please use
AutoML to do it?
And they have very
smart programmers.
And they came in, they
picked up our API service,
created a machine
learning custom model just
for them very quickly, and
were able to launch that
into their shopping experience.
So machine learning at Google
Cloud, it's a bunch of things
altogether.
On the bottom
layer, we've already
talked about hardware
accelerators,
like GPUs and TPUs, and
why they make it faster,
and how you can save time
and money by using them.
But it's also, as the left
shows, about the data.
We have very large
object storage where
you can put in your raw files.
We have BigQuery for
databases and analytics.
We have Dataproc, which does
Hadoop and Spark clusters
for HPC-style workloads.
But then these also, up
the stack from hardware.
We have the Kubernetes engine.
This is a cluster
of servers that
run containers, first class.
And GPUs are integrated
into our Kubernetes engine
where you can go ahead
and run your HPC and ML
workloads on a Kubernetes
cluster with containers.
Or let's say you don't want to
deal with the infrastructure,
containers, or VMs.
We have Cloud ML Engine,
also powered by GPUs.
Cloud ML Engine is you
want to do some training
or inference ML workloads,
but you don't want
to create the infrastructure.
So you just deal with our
APIs, or UI, or Gcloud,
and you say, I would like
to do a TensorFlow job
and train a model.
Please give me the
results, and use this data.
Or I would like to do
predictions and inference
workloads with the model
I just trained, right?
But it's a managed service and
extracts that complexity away
from you.
We also have Kaggle, which is a
great community of ML experts.
And they also do
competitions for ML.
I myself did a
competition in Kaggle.
I learned all about how to
code and use TensorFlow.
It was a competition for
detecting distracted drivers.
There would be a
picture of a driver,
and someone would be looking
and paying attention.
And someone would
be drinking a soda
or talking on the cell phone.
And you had to write code
that would create the ML
model on a GPU and
try to figure out
if that person's distracted.
And companies use
Kaggle to kind of create
AI for their companies.
But people like me, that maybe
aren't experts or weren't
experts, could now go to Kaggle
and ask this community, hey,
I'm trying to do this.
How do I get over this problem?
And the community
helps guide you.
So it's a great resource.
TensorFlow, we talked
about a little bit.
It's an open source ML framework
that anyone can use on-prem
or on Google Cloud.
And it works on CPUs,
GPUs, TPUs, you name it.
And a new project
was called Kubeflow.
This is TensorFlow, in essence,
on Kubernetes clusters.
And it's open source, so
you could run it on-prem,
you could run it on Google
Cloud, or wherever you want.
It's a brand new project
backed by Google.
So altogether, from the
GPU up, machine learning
and Google Cloud, because of the
data services and the high end
services, we think we're
really a great partner.
We want to work
with you on those.
So let's switch context.
Let's look at another problem--
on-premise deployments.
They take time.
Maybe today you have an
existing cluster of servers
with GPU workloads, or
you're considering, hey,
for my new project, do I
want to go do it on-prem,
or use the cloud?
Well, there's a lot of
problems on this sheet--
ordering the stuff, securing
it, installing the pieces,
finding co-location.
And you could do all
of that, and it might
be the right choice for you.
Alternatively, you
could use Google Cloud.
And I'll just talk a little
bit about the benefits of using
GPU compute on Google Cloud.
First is the infrastructure.
We've been doing
this a long time--
building servers, data
centers, innovating on power
and cooling.
And by choosing
Google Cloud, you
get to take the advantage of
using that infrastructure--
large scale compute, some
of the biggest networks,
fiber optic backbone, great
data center networks, high end
security, high
performance storage.
Fast provisioning-- I
showed you a demo earlier
where you can create a
cluster, put it in one VM,
change the number to 1,000.
And a few minutes later,
there you go-- supercomputer.
Security is built-in.
Before Google
launched Cloud, we've
always been caring about
security and privacy and user
trust.
And the Cloud has
been lucky to adopt
a lot of the same
technology we use to protect
Google's other services.
So it's too much to
list here, but we
feel that we are a
security leader in Cloud.
And by choosing Google
Cloud for your GPU workload,
you get that built-in.
And that lower capital--
you don't have to go spend
$250 million on a HPC cluster.
Just spin up some capacity
and run your workloads.
Let's get a little
technical, right?
Bare metal performance on GPUs--
the VM is virtualized,
but the GPUs
are through PCIE
pass-through mode.
And what that means is
the VM has raw access
to the PCI hardware bus, and
you have bare metal performance
for your GPU accelerator.
That applies for all of our
models, the K80, V100 and P100.
Another piece that I really
like about Google Cloud
is the flexibility
and customization.
You're not locked into
a strict ratio of,
I want a small amount
of CPU memory and GPU,
or I have to get a big amount
of all of those things.
And you're just picking sizes.
But instead, you can create
a custom VM shaped for you.
What amount of CPU do you
need for your exact workload?
How much host memory?
What type of GPU--
K80, P100, V100?
How many GPUs?
And what kind of storage-
network, spinning disk,
network SSD, or in-server SSD?
And that flexibility,
it gives you
super high performance,
if you want it,
or lower cost, if
that's more preferred.
But what normal customers do,
they find the right balance.
What actually do they
need for their workload?
And they can eliminate
the infrastructure
that they don't need
and just save money.
Per second billing-- this is
great because you only get
paid for the exact seconds that
you use the infrastructure.
We also have something called
sustained usage discounts which
is, if you just use it
for a long period of time,
we automatically deduct
up to 30% of your bill.
And then there's the
benefits of Google Cloud--
just it's an end-to-end
stack, it's huge data,
managed services, function
as a service containers.
And use GPUs any way you want.
So here's our portfolio.
I like to think of it as small,
medium, and large GPU, right?
They vary between
performance and price.
K80 is the workhorse.
It's three generations old.
It's also the lowest price
and the lowest performance,
but it's still much
faster than CPUs.
It has 12 gigs of memory.
It's in many
different locations.
You can get between one and
eight of those in a single VM.
One generation newer--
the Pascal P100.
It's great for compute
and visualization.
It has more memory--
16 gigabytes.
And it comes with one,
two, or four GPUs per VM
and up to 96 vCPUs,
or 624 system memory.
And the brand new GPU
that we just launched
with our team, the Volta V100.
And this thing literally is a
supercomputer in a single VM.
You can get up to
eight of these.
They're SMX 3 chip set.
It's the V100, and they come
with special NV Link GPU
to GPU communication for
ultra high performance.
And this GPU's specifically
great for ML workloads,
due to its mixed precision.
It's not just floating point
64 precision like the others,
it also has this mixed
floating point 16/32 precision
that ML really speeds up.
So let's look at
another problem.
Maybe not on-prem, but what
if I use a different cloud?
How can I save money compared
to that other cloud for my GPU
workload?
Well, I think the
best way to show you
this is just another demo.
So let's go back to the
Google Cloud console
and show you what
to do with this.
So here I am at the
Google Cloud console.
I'm going to go away
from instance groups,
and just go right
to VM instances.
I'm going to create an instance.
And let's call this--
since I'm a New York
Rangers hockey fan,
let's say, Let's
Go Rangers GPU one.
We'll pick a location.
Iowa seems fine-- US Central 1F.
And we'll go to the
Customize field.
Now maybe in other
cloud providers,
what you'd have is your
CPU and your memory.
And your GPU will
scale linearly.
If you want one
P100 GPU, let's say,
you're going to have
cores of memory that
goes along with that.
No option, otherwise.
Or if you want four P100s
with another provider,
you'll have to get the
cores and the memory that
go along with that.
And because of that, your price
per month is going to increase.
This is showing you
$4,455 per month for this.
So the first way
to save money is
we get something called
sustained usage discount.
So just by using us for
a long period of time
for maybe a workload that
keeps going and going,
not just for one
VM, but think of it
as for the
infrastructure, if you use
a GPU or a VM for a while,
we just automatically
give you discounts--
up to 30% for that month.
It's this amazing saving.
You don't have to do a
contract, just save right away.
So that's one option.
Another way to save money on GPU
compute is the customization.
Well, let's say I don't need
62 cores with my four GPUs,
because maybe my
workload does all
the pre-processing elsewhere.
So let's just bring back
down the number of cores.
And for host memory, well, we
only use the GP memory, right?
That's faster.
It's quicker.
We don't need a
lot of host memory,
so let's bring that down.
So just by sliding this down,
because maybe your application
doesn't need it, we've
saved even more money.
We took it from roughly
$4,300 to $3,100.
How about another way?
Let's give you another option
to save money on Google Cloud.
So we have something
called preemptible VMs.
And if I just go down
here, click on Management,
there's an option, do you
want a preemptible or not?
If I say yes, now I'll notice
I just saved another $1,000.
And what a preemptible
VM is, Google's
spare capacity that we might
not be able to sell elsewhere.
If you're willing to use it
with certain limitations,
you can save more money.
So there are a wide
range of areas on how
you can save on GPU instances.
So let's switch back and
tell you a little bit more
about cloud GPUs.
So let's double-click
on Preemptible GPUs.
I kind of hinted
at them just now.
And what they are, it's
a win-win for everybody.
Google Cloud might have a
little extra GPU capacity.
And what we do is we
expose them to you
through preemptible GPUs.
Now there's a limitation.
The limitation is the
VM itself can only
last for up to 24 hours.
And we might have to take
that VM away from you
if someone else needs it.
But in exchange for that, the
CPU and memory will be 80% off,
and the GPUs will be 50% off.
That's just a clear
way to win-win.
So if you have a batch workload,
like a big training job,
and you want to save some money,
go ahead and create a managed
instance group.
Say you want 1,000
VMs with V100 GPUs.
And if we have the
capacity, you'll get it.
And write your code,
let's say TensorFlow code,
to do automatic checkpointing
where, as it's doing the work,
it saves the work, so that
if the VM comes back online
once we have capacity, it just
takes over and picks back up.
So if you're willing to
automate some of your work,
you can save some money
through preemptible GPUs.
So what about it being
hard to use GPUs?
Well, I guess it's
harder than using CPUs.
It's harder in the
sense where you're
going to write some code, or
you download an application,
and in the code
sense, maybe you have
to write some new
TensorFlow code.
Just say, don't
use CPU, use GPU,
and TensorFlow takes
care of the rest.
Or if you have an
HPC software, just
get it that it's
GPU-enabled, and it
will work right out of the box.
But what about Google Cloud?
What do we do to make it easier?
So the first thing,
we integrate GPUs
across the stack of services.
So far, I've showed
you Compute Engine,
about how getting VMs with
GPUs is quick and easy.
But it's also integrated
with Container Engine.
Go ahead and get your
cluster of container
enabled Kubernetes engine
machines with GPUs,
and we'll run your docker
or container workflows
through there.
Cloud Machine Learning
Engine, the managed service
for training and inference
machine learning, that's
also integrated with GPUs.
So you don't have to deal
with the infrastructure.
You don't have to deal with
the complexities of building
from source TensorFlow
and things like that.
You just want to run your
job, so just go ahead
and work in code.
Or Dataproc, Hadoop and
Spark clusters as a service,
also give you VMs and
infrastructure with GPUs.
And you don't have to worry
about the complexities
of managing that.
And then the fifth service
with integrate GPUs is Zync.
Zync is our cloud video
broadcasting service
with a wide range
of things, as far
as transcoding or rendering.
And it's powered, if
you want, by GPUs.
So let's look at another
problem out there.
Let's say your workload
really demands the highest
performance.
And then you say, I could
run CPUs, I could run a K80.
Well, Google has you
covered there too.
We've just launched
the Tesla V100 GPU.
This is the latest
GPU from NVIDIA.
It has up to a petaflop of
performance in a single VM.
And that petaflop of performance
in one VM comes from eight GPUs
and with mixed precision.
And this mixed
precision means when
you're doing a math that's maybe
not super, super accurate--
and engineering
simulations need that,
but machine learning
workloads don't.
So it's great for that.
V100s also come with NV Link.
And what that means is we
have a special hardware board
where our eight GPUs
are connected together.
And on that hardware board,
we use NV Link 2.0 technology
that gives 300 gigabytes
per second of bandwidth
between these GPUs.
So in a way, it kind
of creates a system
where it's such high
performance between these GPUs,
you could think of a
collection of GPUs as one.
You could use more GPU memory
for fast ML and HPC workloads.
You could transfer data between
these GPUs really quickly.
And you'll notice that, if
you just scale out by saying,
give me 1,000 VMs with one
GPU each, that definitely
gets you done faster.
But as you go,
please give me one
VM with NV Link high speed
network with multiple GPUs.
The benefits there
are even better.
We've noticed that up to
40% faster performance just
for your deep learning, machine
learning, or HPC workloads,
just by turning on an
NV Link on the V100.
So it's a super fast,
super quick GPU,
and we just launched it.
Try it out.
So it's not just about GPUs.
We want you to pick
Google Cloud because we
want you to see us as the
leaders in infrastructure.
We were very early
with Skylake CPUs
on Google Cloud that
literally worked with almost
any workload imaginable--
web apps, databases.
They don't do great
on visualization,
but they're not meant to.
So then if you want to get
a little bit more specific,
but still generic, use GPUs.
Machine learning, HPC, video
transcoding, movie rendering,
visualization, they speed
up all of those workloads.
And then we also have
the TPU, a special chip
just for machine
learning workloads.
TensorFlow, the library
for machine learning
that's open sourced,
works across all of those.
So we talked a lot about
GPUs and the benefits
of Google Cloud.
Let's just briefly
talk about a couple
of customers that
use Cloud GPUs.
The first one is Schlumberger.
Schlumberger is one
of the leading oil
and gas [? services ?] company.
And as this pictures show,
one of the services they do
is they have these sensor
units floating in the ocean.
And they send a whole bunch
of signals down to the ground,
and they get a lot of
data-- sonar, radar,
a bunch of things.
And they just collect that
data, and they ship it
to Google Cloud.
Google Cloud, they have a
cluster of infrastructure
with NVIDIA GPUs.
And they process that data.
And the end result of
processing that data
and doing lots and
lots of math is
they're able to create a map.
And that map will show
them and their customers
how deep the ocean is,
where might there be oil,
where might there
be sand or rock
and how would you get to it.
And those HPC clusters with
on-demand provisioning,
versus on-premise high
capital expenditures
was one of the reasons that
drove them to Google Cloud,
in addition to our
security, our reliability,
and our partnership with
AI services moving forward.
Let's look at one more, Shazam.
So I'm really, really
bad at music trivia.
When I go camping with my wife
and friends, we'll put the iPod
or iPad up.
We'll shuffle some songs.
And my wife will just
dominate me in this game.
So I love Shazam.
Shazam's an app where, if
you hear a song on the radio,
and you don't know what
it is, or at the mall,
you pull the app out,
you hit a button,
and it listens to the song, and
it tells you very quickly what
the name and the artist is,
and lets you listen to it,
and things like that.
And what they do
on Google Cloud is
they do a lot of data
processing with GPUs
and to make those really
quick predictions of,
hey, I heard the song,
it's probably this song,
or it is the song.
They load that information
on databases, on GPUs,
to give very quick
inference workload results.
So in short, 99 problems,
but a cloud GPU ain't one.
I hope you get started
with Cloud GPU soon.
If you're new to
Google Cloud, you
can sign up, get a
free credit, $300,
and sign yourself
up for some GPUs.
There's a couple of links here.
And the documentation
will show you
how to create a GPU with a VM.
And then there's also
information about preemptible.
Now, we're going to
take a little break.
We're going to
find what questions
might be online and come
back with those answers.
Be right back.
Great, and welcome back.
So on the list here,
we have some questions.
And we'll just go through
them one at a time.
So the first question--
what's on the roadmap in terms
of new infrastructure
hardware on Google Cloud?
Well, it's a great question.
In general, it's going to
be what the customers want.
NVIDIA keeps releasing new GPUs.
We just launched the V100.
They made some announcements
of what might come next.
There's always
interest on those.
So as they launch
new high end GPUs,
we'll probably be
bringing those in.
And also just like
the cloud TPU,
we focus on what
workloads are out there
and what other
infrastructure hardware
might we continue to bring in.
So as customers demand faster,
higher price performance
ratios for
infrastructure, we'll look
at new hardware accelerators.
But just like GCE, it's not
just about those hardware
accelerators.
We'll also look at things like
what kind of CPU, memory, disc,
network.
And you can think
of Google always
pushing forward on all of this.
Second question--
what type of workloads
are a good fit for the V100 GPU?
Really, there's two.
One is machine learning.
Because of the mix precision
support and the NV Link
connections between
the GPUs, this
is a very optimal
machine learning GPU.
A lot of our customers are
using these in large scale
to do machine learning
training, starting
to do some inference
workloads with Tensor RT.
Great for ML, but also
just really good for high
demanding HPC workloads.
If you really want your
results done quickly and fast,
it's a great GPU
for that as well.
So the next question--
can you have both
preemptible and dedicated VMs
in the same cluster?
Another good question.
So you can, yes, in both
GCE and Kubernetes engine.
So on GCE, there's two
types of instance groups--
a managed instance
group, and an unmanaged.
In the managed
instance group, we
do things like auto-scaling
and rolling back code.
And with a managed
instance group,
we want the same type of VM,
the same shape and so on and so
forth.
So for that, we say it has to
be the same kind of template.
But an unmanaged instance
group, there, you
can put whatever VMs
you want into a group.
It could be dedicated.
It could be preemptible.
And it could scale as you need.
Then the third way is you could
just have two instance groups.
You could have a
managed instance group,
both managed instance group,
one dedicated, one preemptible.
And you could have one
capacity change over time
with availability, and the
other one always there.
So that's what a lot of
our customers do on GCE.
On Kubernetes engine, you
have something similar.
Kubernetes engine has
the notion of node pools.
And you could have one pool
of nodes be preemptible,
and another node
pool being dedicated.
And you can scale that
side differently, as well.
So both of them have an
option to do it, yes.
Let's look at the next question.
What would I need to do
to use preemptible GPUs
at large scales on GCE?
So with GCE, the demo
I just showed you,
that's one way--
a managed instance
group, you create a template,
and you scale up the instance
group to the size you want.
In order to get that, there
are a couple of things
you have to do first.
You have to have an
account, and then you
need what's called quota.
Quota is a way to make sure
that the customers that
are using capacity are the ones
that are the right customers
to use so in some way.
So at first, you'll have
a small amount of quota.
And if you really want to
run a cluster of 100 GPUs,
or 1,000, or even more, just go
online, go to the quota system
and say, this is the amount,
the max I want to run.
Make a submission, and
we'll get back to you
shortly with what you're
allowed to go up to.
So those two things, managed
instance group and quota,
will get you that scale.
Or same thing with
Kubernetes, right?
You get a Kubernetes
cluster or get some quota,
and then you can
get up and running.
Next question-- when should
I look at TPUs or GPUs
for ML workloads?
Well, that's another
good question.
I think both TPUs and GPUs are
going to be a great fit for ML.
GPUs are going to
be a little bit more
generic, kind of work good for
all workloads, all libraries--
TensorFlow, PyTorch, Skylake,
[? Keris. ?] You name it,
it's going to work.
And so it'll work for inference.
It's going to work for training.
TPUs, they're going to be very
specific to the TensorFlow,
for now, library.
And it's also good for
very specific models.
And it's going to be really
good from a price performance
perspective for those
models it works.
So at Google Cloud,
you could use either.
We hope you do use
the one you want.
And we'll keep launching
new generations
and for better
price performance.
We'll keep launching
new features that
make it even easier to
support ML workloads on GCE.
And last question--
are there any plans
to offer AMD GPUs
on Google Cloud?
At this time, we
just do NVIDIA GPUs,
but we're talking to
some customers that
have expressed interest.
So if you have interest
for AMD, just reach out--